e herkese Merhaba Ceren Gündoğdu bu
takvimler 25 kısım 2020 gösteriyor 25
Kasım kadına yönelik şiddete karşı
uluslararası mücadele Günü ilan etmiş
Peki bir tarihin tekniğine var Bizler
bugün bu tarihin kaynağındaki
dirilişimiz 60. yılındayız 1960 yılına
doğru cumhuriyeti'nden ülkenin özgürlüğü
için mücadele eden üç kız kardeş o
dönemki diktatörlük tarafından
öldürülüyor eski Merhaba kardeşlerin en
küçüğü gördüğünüz 25 yaşında olan
yaşadığım kendi kendime şu sordum ben
nereden bulacağım ya geçmişten bir
hikaye geldi geçmişteki acı bir hikaye
başlamak istedim diye ve içtenlikle şu
cevabı verebilirim sanırım sebebi
geçmişteki adını tutulmak değil Aksine
o Geçmişte yaşanan acı olayların
geçmişte yapılan hataların günümüze ve
yağımızı sirayet etmesini engellemek
istemek onun çabası Galiba tam olarak da
bu sebepten ötürü bence Biz Kadınlar
olarak ortak bir hedefin etrafında
toplanabiliyor uzakta Bana kalırsa söz
konusu olan ortak bir değil iki ders var
o kadına yönelik şiddetin ortadan
kaldırılması ve daha şiddetin psikolojik
boyutuyla bağlantılı olduğunu düşündüğüm
bir mevzu kendimiz gibi olabilmek
kendimiz gibi olabilme özgürlüğüne sahip
olabilmektedir Yusuf kadına yönelik
şiddetin ortadan kaldırılması için ne
önemli diye düşündüm de çok fazla şey
var bahsedilmesi gereken Belki ben bu
kısa zamanda özellikle benim için önem
arz ettiğini düşünür şeyleri sizinle
paylaşacağım şu
bu şiddetin normalleştirilmesi ve
cinayeti normalleştirilmesi çok
tehlikeli bulunma bunların normal
değiştirmesini engellemek için de tepki
veriyor Biz gerekiyor o yüzden tepkisiz
kalmak çok büyük bir tehlike Gazi
ediyorum Bana kalırsa Bu tepki sizin
temelinde korkularımız olabilir pembe
Ellerimiz olabilir vurdumduymazlığı mı
olabilir fakat ne zaman ki tepki
veriyoruz ne zaman ki masaya yumruğumuzu
vuruyoruz ve yanlış giden şeyleri
konuşmaktan çekiyoruz o zaman bahşet
gibi şiddet gibi yanlış olgularında
normal geçmesine karşı bir siper almış
oluyoruz Bana kalırsa Bu yüzden
tepkileri yolunu çok önemli olduğunu
düşünüyorum ve hayal ettiğimiz eşit ve
özgür yaşama hakkına sahip olan
kadınların bir aldı toplum olgusu Ancak
ve ancak
o diğeri vermemiz var ve de kadınların
eğitim hakkına sosyal ve siyasal alanda
var olabilme hakkına sahip çıkmamız
lazım oluyor Bana kalırsa
Sen niye ortak hedefinizden bahsedecek
olursak ki ben galiba birazcık daha
fazla olmakla konuşmak istiyorum Bugün
gördüğünüz gibi olabilmesi Sevdamız
mücadelemiz dan Çünkü ben devrimci Sen
bir kadın olarak şarkı söylemeye
başladığımdan beri kendimi bildim bileli
şarkı söylüyorum sürekli olarak etraftan
ilk şekilde giyimx şekilde kuruş şöyle
bir şarkı yapmış sosyal medyadaki
fotoğrafın altına şöyle bir not yaz
Şöyle bir saat yapmayı soğuk tutar gibi
hep çok saçma sapan bilgiyle kuş
atıyorum bile denmez bu hafta yorumlanan
daha doğrusu galiba bu yorumlar bize tek
geçsin istiyorum çünkü Eğer bu yorumlar
bana ya da bir başkasına size tek geçmez
de bir şekilde içimizde yenilenirse İşte
o noktada özgüvenimizi kuruluyor Ozan
kelimesinin
tek bir kelime olduğunu düşünüyorum
çünkü kendi kendine bu sorguladığımda
yani Biz ne oluyordu sosyal baskın bu
kadar etkisi altında kuruyoruz ne
oluyordu kendi kendimize bu kadar
baskılama ya başlıyoruz ne olduğunu da
kusursuz bir kadın olmalıyım yanılmasına
düşüp kendi kendimize şiddetli
uyguluyoruz gözlerimizi kaybediyoruz
oluyor Ne oluyor sana kalırsa
sosyolojiye giriş derslerinin Bu bir şey
var ilk derslerimizde biriydi tahtaya
kadın yazdı buraya erkek yazdığı kadının
altına eksik kromozomlarını erkeğin
ağzını x y kromozomları yazdı Aslında
kadın ve erkek olgusu
Allah iyilik bir açıklamaya çok basit
şekilde doğruyoruz fakat toplumsal
cinsiyet kavramları Bu kadar basit
açıkladığı 12 sebebiyle açıklanır Çünkü
onlar Bizim olduğumuz şeyler programlar
sanki böyle bilmediği ilginç post etkisi
gibi Aslında bize nasıl yaşamanız
gerektiğini söyleyen kurallar ve bu
kurallar bizim özenle elimizdeki değer
yargılarıyla isteklerimizi
hayallerimizle tutkularımız Lara
çarpışırsa son noktada özgüvenimizi
kaybetme başlıyoruz Aslında
bilinçaltımızda işleyen bir kültürün
tanımına sıkışmış oluyoruz kırışıklıktan
kurtulmak için kendimiz gibi olabilmek
için ne yapmalıyız Bana kalırsa Hatta
bana kalırsa değil kutlar yaparsan
kadınlar kitabın alıyoruz yapmak
istiyorum Çok hoşuma giden bir cümle bu
elbiselerimizi çıkartıp atın söküp Batın
onun yerine
Ben seninle gerçek bilginin elbiselerini
giydim yoksa içgüdünün ve Gerçek değil
Şimdi bu iki kavramı beni birazcık
düşünecek olursak 3 gibi lerimiz Aslında
bize ne istediğimizi söyleyen şey yani
en basitinden bu bölümü okumak istiyorum
ben bu işi yapmak istiyorum ben böyle
bir anne olmak istiyorum ben anlamadım
istemiyorum Ben böyle yine böyle yaşamak
istiyorum gibi gibi gibi bu cümleleri
yüzlerce örnekleri çoğaltabiliriz
içgüdüleri dinleyip Aslında bu
isteklerin bu isteklere Sadık kalarak
fotoğraftan öyle alemden sorumluluk
Sadık kalarak yürümek çok önemli aday
oldu hayatımda bilgi konusunda zaten
Demin de altını çizdiği kadınların
eğitim hakkına sahip olması çok önemli
da kendimiz gibi olabildiğimiz anlamış
olduğumu biliyorum ve Bence en büyük
mücadele Aslında mutlu bir insan
olabilmeyi başarabilmek bir mücadeleden
söz ediyoruz mücadelenin olduğu her
yerde beni unutsan da bahsetmek lazım
Kendi buldu mu kendim gibi olabilme
savaşımı Aslında müzikle görüyorum Şimdi
kendimi en iyi ifade edebildiğim olan
müzik Umuyorum ki gün gelecek her genç
kadın her kadın kendi tutkusunun
peşinden giderek üreterek hayatın
içerisinde var görünecek O noktaya
geldiğimizde zaten başta konuştuğumuz
eşit ve Özgür Yaşam hakkına sahip
bu kadınların olduğu toplumun toplum
düzeyine ulaşmış hız gibi olacak Ben de
sana şarkı söyleyeceğim dedikleri üzere
şarkısını yaklaşık 30-40 yıl önce
yazılmış bir şarkı hakkımız hala
güncelliğini koruyor bir şarkı ile yazar
etmek istediğimiz sorunları gözardı
etmek yerine bu sorunlar hakkında
konuşabiliyorum Amca çok büyük bir güç
birazcık bunu da yapıyor isterseniz de
şarkı içinde çabuk söyleyeyim Sonra
ufacık konuşmaya devam ederiz bir tane
de kendi şarkılarını söyler misiniz
O kim de ben Siraç koydum biliyor musun
[Müzik]
Bir şey sormuyorum Hadi hiçbir şey sorun
olur şe e
[Müzik]
bir diş ördüm gider çok iş sizin o
Hı hı hı
o kilimdeki Aşık Zeynep tutuyorum da zor
[Müzik]
hiçbir şey o
o çocuk kadın İkisinde de o o o o
bu savaş
mı böyle Buyurun kimdi sensin soru
geliyor yoksa musun Sarı
Yok yavrum ya Sesin çok güzel olsun
hiçbir şey ya
ne bilgisi sormaya devam ettiğiniz
müddette hoşumuza gitmeyen bizi
sınırlandıran bize zarar veren şeylerin
neden böyle olduğunu sormaya devam
ettiğiniz müddette Ve umut var Bana
kalırsa
en son şarkı daha söyleyeceğim size
kendi şarkılarından birini tam döneminde
yazdığım şarkıyı çok beğeniyorum da
bitmiş 6000l ikimiz şarkının adı biraz
birşeyin hikayesini yansıtıyorlar Baba
şarkı çok zor zamanlardan geçtik
endişeli korku korktuğumuz belirsizlikle
mücadele ettiğini zamanlardan Dünya ne
kadar zoruna kadar karanlık olsa bile
bile hepimizin hayatında bir kişi
birileri ya da bir tutku bir olgu vardır
hayatı hayatı yaşanılabilir kuruyor
Herşeye rağmen güzel kılıyor şeye rağmen
bizim sevgimizi sağlıyor
O biraz işte O kişi kişiler ya da oldu
Neyse onlara teşekkür mahiyetinde çıktı
şarkı geçmeden Evvel Benim için kadına
yönelik şiddetle mücadelede önemli
olduğunu söyleyeyim son General
olduğundan bahsetmek istiyorum şey
çıkmıyor önce bazı kavramları üzerine
topluca yeniden düşünmeliyiz Doğu
kavramlarının anlamları üzerinde yeniden
mutabık olmalıyız bazı kelimeler geçiyor
kafamdan mesela kadın cinayetleri
deneyeceğiz ne olur yüze şarkısında
aslında da altı çizildi göre namus
kavramı üçburun egemenlik kavramı tarih
kavramı tarih nedir mesela bana göre
tarz olması sana göre taciz olmalı ki
bir problem yaşamıyor Yani bu
kavramların yeniden tanımlanması
gerekiyor bence İşte tam olarak da bu
bu hakları politik adaletin şiddetin
olmadığı bu olmadı bir kadına yönelik
şiddetin var olmadığı bir dünyanın iğne
ayarı ütopik bir şey olmadığına
inanıyorum ben mücadele olduğu müddetçe
umut var Onu diyorum ki de eşit daha
özgür daha Korkusuz olduğumuz günler
gelecek Onlar da sevdiğiniz şeyleri
takılarak üreterek kararlarınızı peşinde
koşarak kendimizi var etmeyi
başkalarından bağımsız olarak kendimizi
var etmeyi başardınız müddeti
gerçekleşecek Bence bu Hayaller Bu
trafik gözü Kerem Aslı hiç kötülük
olmayan bu güzel dünya düzeni hayalet
gibiyim ve dünyada ikimizi devam edeyim
abone ol
bu dünyada sen Zeynep mı
bu üstüne o
o o of Google Google Google Google
[Müzik]
O çok güzel Herkese çok teşekkür
ediyorum beni dinlediğiniz için
Hoşçakalın görüşmek üzere